so if you know you're getting feedback or you got noise in your room please
mute yourself. Okay so you know everybody it is April but I think it's the 74th
day of January here in Minnesota because we got a lot of snow this weekend I
think about 18 inches where we live. So we're not here to talk about the snow, we
heard talk about other things. We got a couple questions emailed and then we will
open it up for questions so we're going to just talk about questions and try to
answer as many questions as we can and and I will say that if we could please
if you know if we don't have any questions that's fine but if we could limit to
one question a person maybe two that would be better because people are asking
for that. Here was a question that came in and says when we start to clean up our
diet and we start to eliminate processed foods and gluten and dairy and soy and
animal protein would this cause withdrawal symptoms from MSGs, glutamates, etc.
and cause symptoms like sleepiness and stomach headaches, blah blah blah. Really
really good question because the answer to this is yes it can. So when so
especially with glutamate so if all I are limited if I eliminated even even
gluten so gluten is the protein in wheat and barley and rye it's melted
that has nothing to do with glutamate okay so if I eliminated gluten you could
go on a we could literally go for a withdrawal but it typically you know about
four or five days and you're fine. Eliminated dairy typically not much of a
withdrawal, soy, the only withdrawal that you'd kind of have some weird symptom
that you'd have is that some possible hormone fluctuation because if you had
been using a lot of soy and then you went off of it, soy is an estrogenetic
substance and it can stimulate estrogens so that you can have some hormone
fluctuation till things balance out. But when you talk about eliminating
glutamates, try to eliminate glutamates in your diet and eliminating glutamine from
animal protein that breaks down into glutamate. You're talking about brain function
and yes you could have so typically that's only gonna last a week or so so if
you eliminate if you clean out those things and you're getting those things, these
symptoms most later I would think. But let's talk a little bit about
glutamate because it's an important thing to be careful of and try to eliminate
okay we're getting some feedback so I am going to mute everybody here. So glutamate
is an important thing to eliminate so remember what glutamate is glutamate is a
neurotransmitter that your body makes. Your body makes it through a process of
breaking down glutamine. Glutamine is an amino acid that you consume so glutamine is
in protein. So amino acids are little teeny molecules that make up proteins as
they bind together. So different proteins are just different combinations of
different amino acids. Glutamine is one of those amino acids. Now glutamine is not a
bad guy nor is glutamate a bad guy. It's simply excess glutamate that's a bad guy
for your brain and excess glutamine that can be a very bad guy for cancer because
glutamine can feed cancer. Glutamine converts to glutamate and back and forth.
Glutamate will convert to glutamine. Now glutamate is needed in your brain. It's a
neurotransmitter. It's an excitatory neurotransmitter. It's needed for you to wake up in
the morning. You need glutamine. It's needed for you to pay attention. That's where
glutamine comes in. So glutamine is necessary. It's excitatory. It raises your
brain wave up to a beta wave. So that's where glutamates come in.
Excess glutamate is where really where the problem is. I pulled up some studies here on
this too. Where do we have specific genetic defects? We can convert glutamate to
glutamate quite quickly and that can cause problems. So if a person eats a lot of
protein, so let's say we have a 12-year-old little boy that has ADD-ADHD. Well,
his mechanism of ADD-ADHD can be because all he likes to eat is chicken nuggets and pizza,
which is a lot of animal protein, which is stimulating glutamate production because he's
getting all this glutamine from that protein. Especially if he has some specific
genetic defects that will convert even quicker. Well, glutamate in the brain, so this is a
slide about what happens with glutamate receptors in the brain. All these M-H's here are specific
desired drug targets that they're trying to figure out different ways to target to prevent
this because it's known that excess glutamate causes brain cell death. Excidotoxicity of
brain cells right here, and eventually brain cell death. So glutamate is being targeted
as the major cause of Alzheimer's and even Parkinson's. And certainly ADD-ADHD type conditions, high
levels of glutamate, and you end up with serious problems. So we want cell death when we're
talking about cancer cells, but that's not what this is talking about. This is talking about
brain cells. So high levels of glutamate over time is going to cause brain cell death increase rates
of dementia. And this is what this study here is about of why are there, you know, are dementia rates
are just going through the roof at much earlier ages that the statistics are that within the next 10
years, the majority of people that are going to be pre or in full dementia is going to be,
they don't know how, as a country, we're going to be able to care for everybody. So it is, it's an
important thing to look at. Question came in, can you measure glutamate levels? No, you can't. Well,
I should say yes, there are neurotransmitter testing kits. So you can measure the neurotransmitter levels
and on those neurotransmitter testing kits, you will see glutamate has one of the things that's
measured. The problem is is that they're urinary test kits. And if you test urinary glutamate levels
that is not, you cannot equate that to the levels of glutamate in the brain. So to answer, yes, there
are measurable ways to measure glutamate, but no, they're not accurate for the measurement of
neurotransmitters in the brain. So we can do a neurotransmitter test, and it's a good test,
because you need neurotransmitter's throat, your body, not just your brain, but we're talking about
the damaging effects of high glutamate or problems with the temperament issues and anger or depression,
and we're looking at serotonin levels and dopamine levels, urinary neurotransmitter testing falls
short. It's not an accurate picture of what is going on in the brain. So you have to look at
behavior, you have to look at genetics, and then from that you could extrapolate. So let's say
person has a has a familial dispensation to to dementia, okay, my my mother had dementia,
my father had dementia, my aunt had dementia, my grandmother had dementia. Oh my gosh,
she knows this running in my family. Well, we want to look at your genetics, your DAOA genes,
your glute genes, and other glutamate genes and glutamate genes that could increase a person's
glutamate levels from consumed amino acid glutamine, which if that is the case, then we'd say,
boy, you have these defects in your glutamine genes, you are going to produce excess glutamate,
it would be who of you to try to push out dementia a little farther to decrease animal proteins,
go on a more plant-based diet. So what we have found is that the glutamine in plant proteins
doesn't have the exact same effects as the glutamine in animal proteins, and I don't know why yet,
I haven't found any studies that tell us why yet, but that's just what we found clinically.
So taking those people that let's say you don't even have a genetic test, let's say we just know
that you have dementia in the family, it may be a wise thing to do to go on a more plant-based diet,
to decrease animal proteins, because you are going to decrease glutamate levels.
However, remember, if you're going to solely decrease glutamate levels by decreasing animal proteins,
but not decreasing dietary glutamate levels, well forget it,
well where am I getting dietary glutamate levels? Dietary glutamate levels are found in foods that are
prepared foods. Well why would I have glutamates and prepared foods? Because the food industry
is really smart and they don't care about your health, if we're going to make a product and we want
to sell a lot of it, we'll load it up with glutamates. Glutamates are technically naturally,
are natural substances, so they can be listed as natural flavorings. That's what you see that
on a label, most likely it has glutamates in it. So glutamates are added to foods, because glutamate
is an excitatory neurotransmitter, so it stimulates the glutamate receptors on your tongue.
It is excitatory to the neurons in your brain, here it is excitatory, so excess glutamate causes
excitotoxicity. That was a word coined by Dr. Blaelach, I believe, that excitotoxicity,
that excess excitation of the glutamate receptors actually causes cell death of the brain,
that brain cell. So over time, constant up-regulation of glutamate in the brain causes brain cell death.
But what it does on a temporary basis is when you eat a Dorito with four different types of
glutamates in it, you taste it and you go, wow, this tastes good. I have to get some more of these,
these are delicious. And is it really good? No, it's just excitatory glutamate receptors,
and you think it tastes good because your brain is excited, your brain is turned on.
So that's what's really important. Another question came, is there higher levels of glutamated
red meats than white meats? No, I don't believe so. It's the animal, it's the animal meats,
and we haven't seen the exact same reaction with glutamates in fish. So that's where we put a lot
of you on a diet that contains very little red meat, very little white meat, but you could eat
fish in eggs. So no turkey and chicken, no red meat, which is beef and buffalo, no pork,
no medicine, but turkey and chicken eating a little bit, excuse me, but eating a little bit of fish
tends to be okay. Now, technically if you look at a chart, you google it, there is glutamated fish
as well, but it tends not to have the same exact same reaction and we don't know exactly why.
So I would still try to limit those because we want to decrease our total glutamate output,
especially if we know your genetics already and we know you have defects on the glutamate genes,
you're going to be converting glutamate to glutamate more readily and you will have higher levels
of glutamate, the better what type of amino acid form of glutamate you're getting. So be careful of that.
So this is a slide about glutamate in the braid. Slide we talk about glutamate with cancer.
Here's an interesting article from 2014 articles in frontiers of farbacology. In the article
talked about glutamates and a porter position. So what it does to a cancer stem cell,
and I cut off part of this slide because I thought I could make it an entire talk at itself because
what it does to affect, iron with cancer cells is a whole other thing, but just about how it
increased the viability of cancer stem cells. So remember cancer stem cells are circulating tumor
cells. So when you have even the smallest amount of kids are growing in your body, even much less
than what would be able to be detected with the PET skin. So let's say if I go, I think I want to
get a PET skin, pretend there's no toxicity in a PET skin because I don't know if I have cancer
because my mom had cancer and my uncle had cancer, so I want to get a PET skin too. Then I go get a
PET skin and there's zero cancer showing up at a PET skin. Does that mean I have no cancer?
The answer is no, it doesn't because remember 99% of the population have some cancer
growing in them. That's why when we do an IVG test on somebody that quote unquote does not have
cancer can still come back at a six because they do have some cancer. Their immune system is just
keeping it at bay and keeping it from ever becoming visible at a PET skin or a CT skin or a palpable
or anything clinical or anything even worry about. But you still have circulating tumor cells.
That's what's measured with the IVG. Circulated tumor cells are what are looking
for a place to set up home and raise a family. Their break off cells from a tumor that is circulating
through the body. That's what a cancer stem cell is. Well, this study shows that glutamate and
cystine, glutamate from glutamine, cystine is another amino acids, increases the viability of cancer stem cell.
So it increases the life of cancer stem cell. So it increases the chance of that cancer stem cell
being able to set up home and raise a family someplace else from the primary side of cancer.
That's what's called metastasis. So just another reason to decrease animal proteins.
A question. What about the glutamates that are naturally occurring grains? Well, there are some
glutamates in other foods I would not worry about those. You do need glutamate. It does serve a good
purpose. So we're not just villainizing glutamate here. We're villainizing excess glutamate.
And the truth is, again, we have so much excess glutamate in our diet that it's ridiculous to get back
to the old age old argument. Well, I think the Bible says we're supposed to eat meat. Well, really?
Yes, the Bible says you can eat meat. But how much eat do you think they ate in the Old Testament?
When you were supposed to bring the first fruits and the best of your first fruits for sacrifice
of your flocks, and most people brought a dove. How much meat do you think they were eating?
They were probably eating meat. Maybe if you were wealthy once a week,
the average person in biblical time was probably eating meat maybe once a month or less.
So let's get this in perspective. We're eating meat three times a day, many times six times a day
in the American diet. So we've got to put things in perspective a little bit. So glutamate
can increase cancer stem cell life. Gluters another article from Uncle Target in November 2014
talking about glutamate. Here's the first sentence of the figure here, a schematic overview of metabolic pathways
involving cancer biology. Cancer cells show an increased flux through glycolysis. That's the
warburg effect feeding cancer. So this is how cancer is fed. The pentose phosphate pathway producing
energy for the cancer at high glutamate consumption. So cancer is gobletly glutamate. So we want to
decrease glutamate levels. Another question. How do we know how to manage glutamate
if we have high level intake to have the right levels? Well, like I said, we can't really measure it.
So we have to be reasonable so that we're not going crazy here, right? And we're not just constantly
focusing on our diet. But this is where things like everything we've been talking about for the last
six months, doing the fasting mimicking diet can really help balance our back our metabolism.
So doing the time-restricted eating intermittent fasting, fasting a day a week. Those are the things
that we're talking about. And decreasing, going back to glutamate and foods, decreasing
times that we're eating out. Or when you do eat out, you know, stay away from, you know,
box restaurants that are going to have high glutamate levels in their foods.
Go to places where you could trust that they're that they're biodeorganic, you're getting
organic foods and you're not going to have glutamated your foods. I would trust even a chipotle
before I trust, you know, some of the other restaurants that are out there. Again, I've shared this
before. I went into an Applebee's once and I told the waitress, I said, can you go ask the cook,
what in your menu doesn't have glutamate? Because I'm really, really allergic to glutamate.
It was just a test. So she comes back after about 10 minutes. She said, ah, the chef said that every
single thing on our menu has glutamate. So where does Applebees buy their food? They buy it from
major restaurant, um, uh, supply houses where most restaurants buy their food. And this is what
you're going to get at any of the chain restaurants, really. So you go into restaurants that are more
hometown, mom, pop places that, you know, the older it can develop a relationship with them and
know where they're sourcing their food. Look at where your sourcing your food. Don't buy things. That's
a natural and artificial flavor. It's on it unless it says in there, no glutamates are in the food.
So that's how you could reduce the levels. And then again, like I said, decrease your
animal meat consumption. So we're not talking about being crazy and we're not talking at all about
I'm not going to have any more glutamate in my body. If you did, you die. So that's not the
purpose either where we do see to try to bring things into balance. So because right now we are
out of balance and that's what can be a major fuel source for our cancer. It can be a major cause
of our kids ADD, ADHD issues, behavioral issues, hormonal imbalance and it is the number one
cause for dementia. So we don't want any of those things. So we need to work on those.
Right. So I'm going to open up for questions, but we did have another question that came in about
iodide levels and breast cancer. So different topic, iodide levels and breast cancer. So we can
say iodide levels with any cancer, really, but mainly breast cancer are most the articles about iodide.
So we want iodide levels, or let's say, rephrase that. We don't want our iodide levels to be low.
So iodide levels are being higher, higher than normal. I think normal
iodide levels on saliva or urine test is 100 to 300. And really with somebody with cancer,
we'd really want them maybe 200 to 600-ish. That's what I like to see for iodide levels.
And those are measurable and those are accurate. So it's a good idea to get those measured. The test is
I don't know 80 bucks to do an iodide test. It's pretty simple and pretty easy. And we could
send you out a kit if you're interested in looking at that. If you have higher iodide levels of
1,000, 2,000, that's not necessarily a bad thing. It can be protective to your thyroid as well.
The only thing that I want to ask is what is your source of iodide? Most
supplements out there, people that are supplementing iodide, are using a legal solution,
or another capsule supplement that is using potassium iodide. I'm not a big fan of potassium iodide
because that's not a natural source of iodide. So I'd rather have you get a kelp-based source of iodide,
not a potassium iodide synthetic source. That's the only thing about that. So we should measure
your iodide levels if you have interest in that. Make sure you contact the office.
All right, I am going to unmute everybody and open that up for questions that it could be a totally
different subject matter. So whoever wants to pipe in. This is Christina. I do have a question for you.
You made the homeopathic gadolinium solution for me. I was just wondering if
I should use it until the bottle is gone or if I should use it for a set amount of time.
You could use it until the bottle is gone. Are you having any symptoms that you feel like are
related to the gadolinium? Initially, after I had the contrast, I had some bladder irritation for
about 48 hours. And I just increased my water intake, ended some vegetable juicing and it
seems to clear with that. So since then, no, I haven't had any symptoms.
Okay, good. So for those who might not understand what you speak about gadolinium is used in a
contrast medium die for MRIs. That's very common. And it's generally thought that it's safe.
The problem is that it is an element of the periodic table and there is no studies on whether
it's safe. And there are numerous, numerous reports that people have a very severe toxicity
reactions from gadolinium. So chakdoris is probably the most notorious case of this. His wife,
everybody knows who chakdoris is. His wife had a severe gadolinium toxicity reaction.
There is a great informational website about gadolinium toxicity a few years ago. There was
informational website put up about that by some of the victims of that. Trying to raise awareness.
There has been numerous peer-reviewed research articles showing that it can be very toxic. Now
they have wardings on it. What good are wardings because they never tell any patients about it.
If you've ever had an MRI, did you remember them saying, well, we're using gadolinium and that
can be a very toxic substance. So you should make sure you tell us if you have any toxic reactions
because we better use some key lady substance to get that out of you and we need to warn you about this
probably not. So it is but it but the besides the most severe reactions that people then will
tie back to that and do their own research and figure out that they just got
giant toxicity issue with gadolinium. There's more people with just minor things. So they just don't
feel well after that. The problem is I believe that it could cause a lot of people to tumble down
who's getting an MRI in the first place. People that maybe are not completely well and then they're
getting the toxicity from a contrast dye. That's just not wise. The problem is that the radiologists
and the radiology community is kind of pickle because without the dye they just can't see
the contrast dye is to give a contrast in an imaging study so that they can see the difference
between different tissue types. So without it they lose a lot of that ability to see that.
Well then you get to well maybe we should do some different you know types of image eater studies.
So it's it is a catch 22 that's out there if you're if you have compromised detox pathways
that's going to be worse. It is not I'm not seeing any studies showing which pathway
gadolinium detoxifies through. Most likely it's the PUN1 pathway but I'm not for sure because most
a lot of heavy metals detoxify through the PUN1 pathway. So if we had somebody's genetics and we
could look at wow you have a lot of PUN1 defects maybe you should not get the contrast dye or just skip
the MRI altogether. That would probably be our best bet as far as trying to look at it
free doing the MRI contrast and prevent any deal. But yes what Christine is talking about is
we do have a whole wheel path for gadolinium. So a whole wheel path helps detoxify a substance very
gently. If someone is very tox or has a very toxic reaction to gadolinium then we probably have to
go a little bit stronger than a homeopath and use a stronger key later. So and those are there's
some different key layers that we use and have different strengths quote unquote pull it it out. So
hopefully that helps. Now there's another it's probably related to another question is that the
the radiation from you don't get radiation from an MRI but you get radiation from a PET
scan and from a CT scan and we have a homeopath for the radiation toxicity to help pull that out
on that helps as well. So none of these things are perfect.
Another question came in about the question that Mike posted on the Facebook page about the hydrogen
peroxide therapy. I forgot to add that to the slide presentation. Sorry about that Mike but if
you guys did get a chance to look at that please look at his question and I'll try to remember to
maybe make a presentation and put it a slide presentation about it. But there are some people
that are using hydrogen peroxide therapy as a therapy for cancer. I'm not a big advocate for it.
We do have hydrogen peroxide on the shelf here and we test people for it on a regular basis
in the only people that it tends to come up with to use hydrogen peroxide as a therapy are people with
chronic blood. Now I can understand the mechanism how hydrogen peroxide could be beneficial for a
chronic biotoxin because the oxidizing agent because that's what hydrogen peroxide is is an oxidizing
agent could be oxidizing to a bacteria you know it killed the bacteria. The problem with an oxidizing
agent is it's oxidizing to our cells and it could cause cancer so that's what we're trying to
decrease in our body is all the oxidizing agents chemical toxicities of things are oxidizing agents
that's why you know pesticides and everything all these things could oxidize the cell membranes damage
our cell membranes and decrease the viability of cells and increase cancer so there's thousands of
studies that relate to that so I just don't see hydro peroxide as a is a real viable solution for
cancer so I could get more into that presentation back to the iodine is for for table salt if we're
going to use limited amounts is there something better than another like the sea salt and the Himalayan
salt is that so you'd want so for salt if you're using salt I would not be using any white salt
if people go whoa I want the white salt because it's iodide it's got iodide I don't want to have low iodide
levels stuck in white thyroid well white salt is horrible for you and the iodide it is potassium iodide so
that's not the right source of iodide either so you're much better off using a sea salt or a Himalayan
salt or you know a Hawaiian black salt and there's many different salts on the market that have minerals
eat it that's the benefit of those salts they have other minerals in it I would not say that that's
not that should be your source of iodide though so your iodide should be if you're getting a natural
source of iodide should be a kelp based iodide is typically you're going to be your best source of iodide
and then what do you think of the Himalayan salt lamps because I hear that they have like amazing
benefits and other people say it's just a big sham well I think there's probably a mixture of both
of those things I think there's benefits to them but I don't think there's amazing as they say they are
that's just leaving it bad I don't think it's going to cure you know your baldness and you know
and everything that they claim that they are so it's just done physiologically possible what you
really think about it so would you hear all these benefits from some different products that you
at least my bite goes huh how does that actually work metabolically that doesn't work that way so
um you know that's where you have to be you just got to think through some of these things
I could see there's benefit it's you know you know doing some things but not what they say
any other questions well I guess since no one else is asking as I've been eating healthier
I've been losing weight and actually losing too much weight and also muscle mass so I know with the
muscle I need to you know try to focus on more protein and exercise but um should I be concerned about
not really having any fat on my body like I'm probably considered underweight and people look at me
and think I'm you know like maybe anorexic but you know I don't know if I should purposely
eat something to try to get fat okay so good question so if we feel like we're losing weight boy
maybe a little lose a little bit too much weight and I don't have the same muscle toe that I used to
um if you eat a whole bunch of protein you're not gonna increase muscle tone you only increase
muscle tone by using the muscle so the only way to increase muscle tone is to is to start
lifting weights or start doing some it doesn't have to be weights but some exercise that's
stimulating muscle growth so just because muscles are made of protein do not take the fly leap that
if I eat more protein I'll have more muscles on my bones it doesn't work that way um carbohydrates
will break down and help make muscle so will fats so I'm not saying you should eat carbohydrates either
but um if don't just equate that as a one-to-one measurement that if I need muscles
muscles are protein so I better eat some animal muscles or something that's gonna be protein
for help me to build muscle the only way for you to build muscle tone is to is to call for more
muscles and the way you call for more muscles is you utilize that muscle so the more you do a biceps
curl the more your brain goes whoa we need to add more muscle there because this this motion
is called for by the pain by the person so we need to lay down more muscle there so you need to do
an exercise program that you're gonna build muscle or increase tone um now you have to have calories
in your body to be able to to do that because if you are under calorieed throughout the entire day so
we talk about fasting mimicking diet we're really under calorieed ourselves but only for a
window of five days um and then you go back to your diet again that you should have ample calories
in order to build muscle and to stay at your weight save day with with uh time restricted eating
or intermittent fasting it doesn't mean that you're under calorie yourself for the entire day
unless your purpose is to lose weight so if a person is overweight and their purpose is to lose weight
then during that time restricted eating that during their feed time they could reduce their calories
and they're gonna lose weight but in your time restricted eating if you're not trying to lose weight
during your feed time you need to consume the calories that you need to consume to do the things
that you need to do which means to maintain your weight and to build muscle quite honestly when
you're trying to build muscle it doesn't make any difference what form the calories you're taking it
in whether it's carbohydrates whether it's fats or whether it's protein but you will not build muscle
unless you exercise but if you start an exercise procedure where you're gonna get some 10 pound weights
and you're gonna google how to build a muscle tone and you're gonna get an exercise chart where you
're gonna do you know 10 overhead pushes and laying out on your on your back and do 10 pushes
straight up and you're gonna do 25 curls and you're gonna so you lay out a program for yourself
whatever you create then you are going to uh be sore yeah but besides being sore you're gonna
call for your body to make more muscle and then it will pull it in from whatever macro nutrient
you're consuming throughout the day what would you say the reverses is true because I feel like I lost
the muscle mass from reducing like my intake of animal protein and but I don't think I did any
less exercise but I got I really lost a lot of muscle I don't think you there's any studies that
will show that you will lose muscle by the decrease of animal proteins and I go you know the simplest
way to get people to understand that is to say is to say look at as look at a gorilla they all they
eat is plant protein and look at how strong they are there is case after case of bodybuilders
that are vegans so it's not about consuming the animal protein that is going to you you could go
eat a whole bunch of animal protein you're not gonna increase muscle mass but if you consume a lot
of calories and you exercise you'll you'll build up that muscle mass okay just uh you have to increase
the calories because if you're going to exercise your body calories right so then you're going to have
a higher uh caloric intake need so make sure you're increasing your hola your chloric intake need
and uh that's where you want to help put on weight another perfect example is my horse okay my horse
does not eat any animal proteins but he's all muscle and if we in my horse my wife's horse is uh
old she's a 30 year old horse and he's he's getting up there at age and he doesn't have very good teeth
and he doesn't he doesn't chew the hay very well he doesn't get the nutritive value of the hay
he can't out of the grass but in the winter if we don't take him in every every day and grade him
he will lose weight and he's going to die but we've kept him alive for another last three years by
giving him some grade every day how grade has zero animal protein right but his body will convert your
body will convert macro nutrients now the macro nutrients are divided as carbohydrates fats are
protein so whatever macro nutrients that you consume if you act like a horse and you walk around
all day and you run around and you call for that need for muscle you will build muscle
but you have to have enough of those macro nutrients on a given day to supply those energy needs too
Dr. Connors this is Deb the volume of that we have to eat for vegetables to get the calories
that you're just saying for muscle building I'm sorry I'm a perfectly incapable of ingesting all that
you're right so that's where that's where you may have to so for person it's like I'm in
weight loss here and I can't keep my weight up that's where you may have to go
to grades I'm doing that maintaining but I'm still like the other person still considered
demonstrated according to other people they're kind of worried about me okay if you're going to eat
a protein source where are you getting your proteins from well I'm eating the vegetarian diet you put
me on yep so there is some vegetarian sources of protein right though I'm doing yeah I'm not
losing anymore but it's just that people are like she said people are looking like you're anorexic
so if you're maintaining and you're not truly underweight but comparatively you've lost a lot of weight
since you know you spent maybe I'm not saying just for you Deb but for a lot of people spend a good
portion of their 40 years of life have been you know 30 pounds overweight and that has been quote-unquote
normal for them and now they're back in a weight that they look very initiated compared to the
way they're used to eat we're not talking about a person who's losing two pounds a week and can't
seem to stop losing two pounds a week but if your weight has leveled off then I would say maintain it
now um what I think Sharon said is that I can't seem to gain my muscle mass so if you're going to start
exercise to try to gain muscle mass you're going to burn through more calories so you're going to have
to add calories to your diet and if you're like I'm already eating a lot of food and I can
don't know if I can add any more calories then you're going to have to look at more concentrated sources
yeah increase your fat you kid use that's why we carry that protein side that chocolate and
vanilla protein that's a all vegan based protein so that's a good protein so there's ways to do it
depending on what you're trying to do okay thank you all right well we're probably should cut off
because we're at about 50 minutes on this call so make sure you email your questions in and um
sorry Mike about that um I did a proximate question I forgot about that so I'll get to that and um
it also asks your questions on Facebook obviously so we want to be able to get to those um 24-7
on that thank you guys uh hopefully it'll all work up here in Minnesota and hopefully it's
a lot warmer where you are head we will see you next week thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you have a good week thank you